So listen to this insanity. So the big business
in the House of Representatives yesterday
was passing Joe Biden's and Democrats one
point nine trillion dollars covid relief bill.
This happened yesterday. It passed without any
Republicans voting for it. We already talked about
that. OK, but that wasn't the end of
the legislative day for the House of
Representatives. Immediately after passing this
bill, the covid relief bill, the House went into
debate about a gun bill. And on days when major
legislation is passed, very often you will have
more news stations and YouTube streams around the
world, even streaming what's going on on the floor
of the House of Representatives. And it just so
happened that because the House went into debate
over H.R. eight, H.R. eight is the bipartisan
Background Checks Act of twenty nineteen. Remember
that 90 percent of the country supports universal
background checks on any gun transaction period.
But most Republicans in the House don't support
it. And because people around the world, after the
vote on covid relief were still watching the
House proceedings, I started getting emails from
viewers. I got an email from a viewer in Belgium
saying, David, did you see that insanity that
Lauren Bobert said about guns on the floor of the
House? A viewer in the UK wrote to me and said,
David, did you see Congressman Madison Cawthorn
saying, come take my guns on the floor of the
House? So I checked it out. And it is truly the
stuff of horrors the world cannot believe how
ridiculous a large portion of our country and our
elected officials are on the topic of guns. Let's
look at some examples here is completely
vapid. Trumpy and Republican Congressman
Madison Cawthorn telling the speaker, I know you
want my guns. Well, try to take them from me.
You want my guns? I know it. We all know it.
Well, Mr. Speaker, you could come and take them
with that. I yield back. Gentlemen, he
is back. The gentleman from New York.
This is one of the foremost legislative bodies
in the United States. And Madison Cawthorn is
yelling at the speaker to come take my guns.
The world is laughing, crying, horrified.
You picket Lauren. Bobert went to the microphone
and argued against universal background checks
based on a story of a man beaten to death outside
her restaurant in Colorado. But the story is a
lie. The man she's referring to actually died
of a drug overdose. Not only is this insane,
it's also a lie. Take a look at this.
There was an altercation outside of my restaurant
where a man was physically beat to death.
There were no weapons involved. He was beat
to death by another man's hands. I have a
lot of young girls who work in my restaurant
and we needed an equalizer.
The story is known to be a lie,
so it's a fake story. Then Republican Congressman
Chip Roy came to the microphone and started
referring to how he has all these weapons,
but he's not going to tell the government
what weapons he has. Defiant and
principled speech. Take a look.
Texans, Americans, the government is never
going to know what weapons are own. Let me
be clear about that. It's not going to happen.
You know, people all over the world see that
and they ask rightly, what the hell
is wrong with the United States of
America? Will these people or what's wrong?
Then Republican Congressman Thomas Massie
also argued against universal background checks on
the basis of a hard to follow hypothetical story
about the victim of domestic violence. Who
needs a gun to make it through the night. I
challenge you follow this hypothetical story.
How many of those hundred and twelve thousand
were prosecuted for that crime of trying to
acquire that gun? According to the DOJ, 12
one to 12 in a year. Who were the other
hundred thousand? Imagine. Just imagine
now that you're the victim of an abusive
relationship and after five years you summon
the courage and the resources to separate from
that relationship, that things have escalated.
And now you've decided it's time to acquire the
means to protect you and your children. So you
go to the gun store and you try to buy a gun. The
clerk presses the computer button. It says denied.
You asked the clerk, why was it denied? I
don't know. This happens sometimes. Maybe
you had a similar name to somebody else in the
database. You can't buy a gun today, tomorrow,
next week, not ever. You've been denied. So
you go to a friend, friend you've known for
a long time. Your friend says, I'd like to
help you. You say, well, I don't know if I'm
going to make it through the night. The friend
says, I'd like to help you, but don't you know,
eight passed and it was signed by the president.
I can't spend a year in a cage. Good luck tonight.
Now, what's extra dumb about that story?
Actually, there's a bunch of stuff that's
extra dumb about that story. First of all,
maybe the person he's describing should call
the police if they think they might not make it
through the night unless they have the imaginary
gun in the hypothetical shootout. But the
problem that Congressman Massie brings up,
someone might be wrongly denied a gun because
their name matches that of someone who
actually can't own a gun. Whether background
checks are universal or not, we already have some
background checks like the name confusion could
happen regardless of whether the background checks
are universal or not. It's a very strange example
to argue we shouldn't. That's an argument for no
background checks at all. We already have some
background checks, not really an argument against
making them universal. So absolutely incredible.
And the world doesn't get it. The world doesn't.
Why is it so embarrassing here in the United
States? These are deep cultural. Educational,
religious, in some cases issues, they are economic
issues as well, in fact, that shouldn't be written
off. There is an economic component to what
we are seeing here, but we have some of the
most radical people we've ever had in the House of
Representatives. And they really have some serious
problems, personal problems, no doubt. But also
these are just the last people that we should have
making law. So another humiliating day globally
for the United States brought to you this time
by the likes of Lauren Bobert and Madison Cawthorn
and some of these other people. Let me know what
you think when you see these rants on the floor of
the House. And then remember Friday, March 26th,
one day, huge membership special. We had a tough
February from the standpoint of memberships
we are trying to recover. I'm getting
so wound up. I just punched my mike.
We are trying to recover. And so Friday,
March 26th, we will be doing a mass
mailing to everybody on our newsletter. You can
sign up at David Pakman dot com for the newsletter
with a one day really powerful, I mean
really powerful membership special.
I would love for you to be one of the
people that gets on the newsletter and
signs up on March 26. All right. We'll take
a quick break and be back right after this.